I hate intro shokugeki no souma season
to really kick things off at the start
of the tournament round in the autumn
elections losers are trying to see who
of the eight remaining contestants will
compete in the first round suma gets
selected to compete first and he's gone
up against the darling of molecular
gastronomy herself Alice the challenge
is to make event they'll lunch and
whoever makes it better proceeds to the
next round Alice uses all this fancy
equipment to whip up a tamari sushi
bento that when eaten an order
complements each flavor even further
leading to euphoria and ultimate food
gasm it's so good in fact that the
director of the school who is one of the
judges goes bare-chested which is a sign
that the dish is truly phenomenal I
don't think there's any real logic
behind the fact that the food was so
good that he has to take his shirt off
but you know you see enough anime you
just kind of start going along with it
one little side note if you remember in
season one the director tasted so much
dish during his entrance exam and nearly
took his shirt off but anyways back to
the competition now it's so much turn
and he use this in molecular gastronomy
of his own gonna do a fun little dance
of the judges being like well that's not
quite good enough and then someone's
like wait there's more like five or six
times in a row and then finally he deals
the killing blow cheap candy gave him
the idea to make some umami pact notis
fears over some rice with some badass
sauce this makes the director show dem
titties and someone goes on to win
knocking Alice out of the tournament in
the first round yep so to pour the
second match of the tournament fizz
Megami is the underdog going in against
the gloomy trio who turns into a maniac
when he's cooking where you get a little
backstory on video from Alice and we
find out that even she can't cook as
well as him he was the head chef of a
restaurant from a very young age and
always carried himself with immense
confidence and bordering psycho levels
of intensity but back to the competition
they are both tasked with making a ramen
and Leo finishes his dish first this
dish is centered around heavy dense
flavors that pack a punch which he made
by using crushed lobster shells Megami
takes the polar opposite approach with a
very light kazuya chicken soy sauce
ramen the judges taste both dishes and
we get this weird metaphorical slugfest
between the dishes and anticipation of
the final decision
episode three the judges give their
ruling and hero is announced to be the
winner
although the crowd helped give support
to Megami after her defeat suma comes
across the dark horse in the competition
who barely qualified in group a Subaru
mimasaka the two of them along with
Takumi and Megami watched the third
match from one of the waiting rooms the
3rd matches between the 2nd guru hi Yama
who is placed up against a Dena's
medicinal secretary Hisako Americans
rejoice as the two of them are tasked
with making a hamburger for the judges
Masako prepares a softshell turtle
burger and ruthlessly slaughters a poor
little guy in front of everybody quick
sidenote the crazy god today from season
1 was really getting her rocks up
watching this but none of that really
matters once high Yama presents his
kebab burger which punches his ticket to
the next round after a swift victory the
fourth match is going to be with the
mysterious new character supa dough who
is revealed to be a massive stalker that
collects all the information he can
about his opponents I'm sure some of you
weirdos can relate he's gonna be going
up against talking me and things get
heated when Subaru insults Tok amis a
little brother and spits on his
Mezzaluna episode 4 because of their
little altercation they both agree to
make their match in Tuba shokugeki the
match gets underway with talking me spit
shine Mezzaluna on the line against
Subarus apology which seems like an
awful been subaru did extensive research
on talk to me to find out not only what
makes him tick but what exactly he is
planning on making for the competition
he then mimics the recipe at the
competition but makes slight
improvements so that he can get the
upper hand he's using this strategy to
obtain 99 prized knives off of people
who have lost to him in shokugeki so
basically he's like the General Grievous
of this show
Subaru predicts everything correctly
about talk to me even the twist that he
tries adding to his dish to keep up with
Subarus alterations this ultimately ends
with taka me using the shokugeki his
Mezzaluna and getting knocked out of the
autumn elections in the last scene
Subaru approaches so much to let him
know that they were put against each
other in the next round
submit a requests to make it a shokugeki
with sohmas knife on the line but soma
instead raises the stakes to have all
100 knives that Subaru has one in his
shokugeki Keys returned to their
rightful owners to have equal value so
my vows to quit cooking all together if
you
gee wonder who's gonna win yeah episode
5 Summa figures Subarus gonna figure out
what he's making anyway so you just
tells him that he's planning on making a
beef sue we are introduced to a new
character meet sudo so testa who is a
reporter that wants exclusive coverage
of sohma's process making his beef stew
Summa Ann Sousa had to ask any man if
she will taste his dish and say what she
thinks
Eddy miss still hate someone so this
takes some convincing along with a
little bit of Ribery but she eventually
comes around to the idea and tells him
that his dish is garbage because it's
not well-suited for this challenge after
mulling this over he figures out what
she met and adds oxtail to the dish to
give it a little bit of kick right out
of the gate episode 6 super little
reveals his twist to be smoked bacon
that he's gonna be using as a garniture
we also find out that he learned what
summer was planning because he looked at
meat Suda's notes after hacking his
computer
fun fact he was able to hack me to his
computer because his password is his
birthday what idiot man responds to
super dudes unorthodox strategy soma
came up with the strategy of his own
since Subarus gonna figure out his plans
anyways he just doesn't plan anything it
brings a bunch of ingredients and meets
with him so that he can cook on the fly
apparently there were other students
that tried using the strategy against
uber too and there shokugeki keys but
not evermore good enough to pull it off
and of course soma wins because he's not
gonna loose it this random side
character that came out of nowhere so
all of the knives have returned to their
rightful owners
except for Takumi's Mezzaluna which he
gives to soma to hold on to until he can
defeat him which i don't think is gonna
happen so hey free Mezzaluna sick
episode 7 the second semi-final match is
coming up in hi Yama is preparing he's
blindfolded by June and has to guess the
ingredients in front of him using only
his nose which all sounds well and good
but the part that's confusing me is why
is he tied to a chair I have to believe
that there's some sort of reward system
that Jun is implementing that I would
love to take part in jump ahead to the
match where the two of them are tasked
with making a western-style dish hi Yama
finishes that first and serves up his
duck dish which was the judges
but Leo isn't out of it yet when he
serves up his eel mátalo which brings
the match to a stalemate the judges are
split with two votes each and the last
judge is two beta to make a decision so
it ends up being a draw the finals are
changed to be a three-way battle between
high gamma yo and so muddy decide the
winner
they're tasked with cooking Pacific
sorry for their dish and the finals
episode the three of them have ten days
to prepare for the finals some mega me
and so my head to the fish market to see
what kind of fresh fish they can find
wouldn't they get there they finally
land Alice there as well
Booth's oh man yo going to know what
determines how fresh the fish is this
turns into a mini competition with both
of them picking different fish that they
think is better
turns out EO is kind of an expert and
put somewhat a shame we're gonna look at
hi Yama who is also able to find the
best fish just by using his nose Zuma is
at a disadvantage to both of his
opponents so he's trying to figure out
how to compensate for the disparity and
skill he ends up deciding to age his
fish and calls in some of the side
characters to help him out with it after
even that isn't enough he gets
discouraged until he gets an idea from
Fumio but we don't see what it is the
finals roll around and the three
contestants reveal their fish as
expected the other two have amazing
choices while sohmas looks discolored
and just downright nasty the episode and
hai the cooking gets underway and Rio is
the first one to finish his dish hey
Carter dojo cooked in herb butter hey
Yama is next to finish his seared
carpaccio the eyes of a witching aroma
when exposed to fire now it's tsoumas
turn to present his salted rice brand
Pacific sorry rice it's good we're not
good enough the director didn't even
take his clothes off and if that doesn't
tell you how good it wasn't I don't know
what well before the decision could be
made someone pulls another cheap
infomercial but wait there's more and
presents his dishes final form episode
10 he whips out a white soup made from
soy milk and pours it over the dish
making it into a porridge we take a
quick detour to learn from Satoshi that
Aizen was actually the one behind Subaru
guiding for soma this was his attempted
revenge on summer for messing with his
client but of course he got shot down we
then get a quick flashback of high
Yama's childhood when he was picked up
by Jun who gave him a home and made him
into the chef he is now the flashback is
some subtle foreshadowing as hi Yama
goes on to win the entire event with the
originality of his dish being the
deciding factor
even after the competition ends the
three of them remain competitive with
one another constantly taste testing
each other's dishes and trying to
challenge one another a few days later
they learn from Jun that the next
challenge is coming up the stasi an
episode 11 the stasi air program
requires students to go work for
restaurants over a week and not only
keep up but find a way to improve the
restaurant before leaving soma is paired
up with Hisako who is still avoiding
Eddie now because of the shame from her
two feet they work at a restaurant that
has sudden floods of customers because
of a nearby train station and the staff
can't keep up to serve all of the
customers soma handles the pressure from
all of the orders just fine by him and
Masako no changes needed so they
brainstorm on how to ensure that the
customers are getting served
they convince the owner to switch to
reservations only which makes everything
more manageable after the week is over
soma convinces Hisako to stop feeling
shame over her defeat and to walk beside
Adina instead of acting like a servant
and walking behind her Masako was never
a huge fan of sohmas thanks to a Dina's
influence but she seems to have grown
fond of him not in the sense that she's
like thirsty for him like meat lady but
she's friendly episode well for the
second part of the stodgy add Toma is
sent out to work with shinomiya at his
new restaurant he works with shinomiya
during the free open in preparation for
the final opening where he falls behind
and can't quite get his bearings this
doesn't discourage him though he stays
up most of the nights learning the
recipes and techniques while also doing
the prep work in the morning so that the
other chefs have more time to answer his
questions
this goes on every day until finally he
starts to get the hang of it and gains
the acceptance of the others the staff
are having a competition amongst
themselves to create a new dish for the
menu and soma gets permission from
shinomiya to enter as well episode 13 on
the Prairie opens final day she no Meah
invites the other alumni as well as his
mother to come enjoy his cooking
afterwards the competition gets underway
and the alumni stick around to see who
wins we don't get to see what the other
staff members made but soma takes
everything he learned to make a French
version of chicken and egg rice bowl
with a risotto stepped quail shinomiya
says that the dish isn't good enough as
is but he likes the concept so he works
with soma to show him how to refine it
and adds it to the menu everyone gets
back to tot ski Academy after passing
the Stars yet his apron says dog dog
now that is a man of culture I bet he
watched his hand tight - what an
inspiration wall away on the sides yeah
the Sohma had gotten a ton of shokugeki
requests and he's eager to start
stomping these nerds out one at a time
starting with the budget Wolverine over
here I'm gonna be doing the future
seasons and that'll be in the bottom
left oh whenever I'm finished with that
or you can check out all the shokugeki
recaps in this playlist here you can
also find the links in the description
below and the only thing I hate more
than intros is outros